how's it going guys how are you graham
i'm good
so steven you're jumping into another
robert kirkman
comic adoption do you feel more prepared
for the
passionate fan base that comes with a
robert kirkman
comic book yeah you know his world and
his universe
is massive um but also very welcoming
so um i'm happy to be here
and i'm happy to um be in
kirkman world um
uh there's a better name yeah that
should be a new sport yeah
yeah right it's just robert thumbs up
but uh yeah you know he's he's a
he's a he's a really wonderful creative
you know
uh genius in that way i think he's made
some things
that a lot of people
didn't know how to access and i'm glad
that he's being able to like put it out
there and he's really captured i think
um the heart of what people want to feel
and say and so i'm i'm excited about it
for sure yeah
very true so jk in the superhero world
you've gone from newspaper editor to
police commissioner now you're actually
superhero how does it feel to finally be
a superhero in the superhero world
finally to be a guy with a mustache
in the superhero world who actually has
some powers
it's a beautiful thing and and you know
not for nothing but
you know nolan is about as about as
powerful as superheroes
as you're gonna find so yeah yeah it's
great it was fun
it's a good one to be yeah and stephen
what i found so refreshing with this
it's kind of sad that it is refreshing
but minorities were played and voiced by
minorities
in this like was that something that
stood out for you about this that there
was proper representation going on in
the cast
um you know yeah sure i think
it's a long answer i think
representation is a process
and um you know right
at this moment what's really wonderful
is that people
are getting opportunities to be seen in
this way and that
people are um making uh choices to make
sure that like
perspectives can be told truthfully from
people from that particular perspective
and i'm happy for that
um i think for this show though you know
when we're
making it the internal process is really
just a human experience
um yeah you know working with jk we
didn't necessarily go into the
full dynamics of all these things
instead we just accepted the terms of
this
of this father and son and i think
that's um
really refreshing in and of itself that
we don't have to um do all this
talk about the delineations of us not
because
those aren't important but because we
accept them already and then we can get
to um
being a father and son and that's always
most rewarding to play out
yeah jake jk i mean this character is
very surprising were you
shocked when you read the scripts about
your character
uh i don't know what you might be
referring to
because i don't ever spoil anything
ever but yeah i mean we continue to see
certainly in my case and in the case of
other characters as well there
you know more continues to be revealed
as we go along that uh that certainly
was not apparent at first and obviously
you know
long time fans of uh of invincible are
going to know what we're talking about
and
hopefully people who uh who don't know
won't know
until uh until certain things unfold so
i think i think
having said that it really and and
stephen and i coming at it from
different
you know steven being very familiar with
uh uh with robert's work in general of
course and with invincible in particular
me being virtually completely unfamiliar
with invincible
before i uh you know was presented with
it um
i think the show that we've all made
together will appeal to both people who
have no idea what's going on
and to hardcore fans right and steven
people are going to be excited that
lauren cohen is on the
pass list for this she just returned the
walking dead to avenge
glenn's death have you talked to her at
all but returning to walking dead have
you watched the episodes
um i haven't caught up yet but i'm
really excited to
um i love those people and um i'm so
glad that robert
put um a lot of our cast
into this show um it's it's a mini
reunion
um i won't i won't spoil how things go
but
um it's always nice to be able to work
with people that i really love
yeah and just finally quickly jk do you
have any oscar advice for stephen
because steven i think minari is going
to win best picture
so jk do you have any advice obviously
there's going to be a different oscars
this year
would you have any advice for the oscars
experience
i have absolutely no advice since we
know
nothing at this point uh my advice is to
uh
enjoy your life yeah that's a good way
to be honest
yeah congratulations guys yeah
congratulations on uh steven it's
absolutely amazing thank you so much
thank you have a great day guys